hey guys sounds like I can still see you
welcome back to my kitchen today we're
gonna be doing a little bit of cooking
but first an unboxing and this is the
pizzazz plus rotating oven sock number
zero 343 I don't know I saw this thing
in Walmart in kawaii when I was on
vacation clearly I couldn't buy this
thing in Hawaii and take it back home
with me on a plane I mean I felt like it
was probably something I can get on
Amazon and guess what I did here it is
and it's time to open it up this is a
life that we live
blessed this thing has been sitting in
my house on the floor for probably two
months every time Jenna comes over she's
like will you please move this stupid
thing today we're moving it we're moving
and grooving prepares frozen precooked
chicken wings nuggets breaded jalapeno
peppers cheese nuggets fish place a
breeze and more it's a big okay nothing
else I should probably keep the
instructions out oh right pizzazz Plus
this is quite the interesting thing
getting acquainted alright it can also
be used to pick cookies and cinnamon
rolls from refrigerated dull and prepare
quesadillas and grilled sandwiches and
seven to 12 inch pizza God if I saw this
thing on tinder I would swipe it the way
that means I want it I don't know which
way that is I need to put the cover back
on this I'll put this far away from my
body before I injure myself I feel like
I should probably wash this in case you
want to actually eat any of the things
that would cook
here we've got our machine oh dang this
is some reading material for mommy so it
looks like this just goes on I think
that's it all right well let's plug it
in wait what am I gonna make let's see
what we've got we've got a Hama hog
drink the pizza we've got some spinach
pizza snacks oh we've got some macaroni
oh Jesus maybe you might like these more
okay we're gonna try to make all this
we're gonna make mac and cheese as well
baby this thing's already turning when
the heating elements are turned on the
metal surrounding heating will expand
you may hear a light humming or
vibrating sound a slight pop as the
metal expands this is normal they say
turn past for to set its Mike this is
must be my time at home I don't feel
anything yet god this smells like
burning plastic that must mean it's
working yeah that doesn't smell good
cheese nugget breadsticks
egg rolls hot pockets potato bread pizza
rolls so sing like 10 to 12 minutes oh
here you go
that's the cheaper way there we go there
we go we go this is gonna be like a
surprise like which one are we gonna get
ah this thing stinks it smells like
burning flesh I'm not on fire that's
good well I'm gonna eat all of these I
guess we wait it feels real it's burnt
like this things are happening yeah this
looks good I feel like the middle
probably isn't gonna get well no
actually the middle will because this is
it's also heating from below you started
from the bottom now we're here that
drink the drink say that what he started
from the bottom and now he's here I
could get Drake to come to my kitchen
and cook with me could you imagine
wonder what we'd make we usually cake
mean to something else that's what I
learned so I was like oh cool this song
is about cake I love cake
mmm we're at our halfway point
challenged we need to get in there and
get under there and see what look at
that there's some stuff happening
burning is happening mmm okay well like
my question is why I just put it in the
friggin oven like if this why is why
this over any other option of ways to
cook anything my small mind does it work
Vladek cameras rollin cuz that like
that's the story that's one for the
books
hurry uh like if this was in the
microwave we would have been done by now
right
I mean like an activity these are like
the prettiest play-doh colors oh yeah I
don't want to play with no no put the
back okay great all right starting to
brown look no something right there
like now I'm just getting a noise like
this is cool this is cool this is like
cruel unusual punishments as we have
like four minutes left we got to see
what level of doneness is that it is
this one looks very crispy Oh juice wow
it's hot it's like these are done done
thing they might be done yeah okay so
like our medal a long metal glass that's
really hot I mean I will say this thing
is working like it's working pretty well
but why is the question
something foolin oh baby oh baby
this one's exploding I think they might
be done so a sure sign of dumbness is
exploding pockets oh just in time he
wants you to say hi to him
may he come here honey come here I got
some pizza pockets yes hallelujah
how to stop this thing from frickin
spitting it look there look what's
happening yeah these look great this is
some Martha Stewart action here Rachael
Ray would be like girl you're so good at
everything making frozen food they're
gonna definitely have me back on chopped
there we go okay now it's time to do
crimes cuz my finger prints just got
turned off baby cried Jen you ready to
do crimes
alright let's taste let's taste so
stupid Jack come try one of these but
wait till it cools offers oh ha Maddy
come here come here oh did you just go
potty cuz I just got a I got AI just got
a touch of PM and I should probably wash
my hand cuz I pee on it let's see if
it's cooked to your liking well usually
I put them in the microwave so this is
already uh it's too hot just take a bite
Prince what do you think of the
temperature do you think it's cooked
well yeah it looks the same way when I
put it in the microwave though yeah but
not as crispy oh good here alright guys
that's it thanks for watching number one
does the pizzaz Pizza plus rotating up
and work yes yes it does should you get
one probably do you need it yes if you
don't have an oven that's all we have
today guys let me know if there's
anything else fun and crazy and cool
maybe potentially useful that I should
unbox here in my kitchen and I'll see
you guys in the next video bye
[Music]